i think men in general are a lot
less accomplished at being vulnerable in
the presence of other people
you know and it's so like yeah i can
write
songs where i bear my soul but bearing
my soul in the presence of
one person you know a friend a family
member someone i'm dating like
that's that's the hardest part
i'm curious what you how you feel about
it but it feels like we're
entering into a phase where um
the fact that there's even that
awareness that
it's harder for men and it i think it is
i think there's a
primal reason i think that there's um
a cultural reason uh i think that
there's
the masculinity in general is um
you know is its own thing and so but i
feel like we're in a phase now where
where men are aware of it and that is
the first step too it's kind of like
saying like
hi my name is so-and-so and i'm uh
whatever do you feel that
do you feel like an opening now like
that you know maybe just maybe you could
sit in front of uh
some someone a friend or a partner or
whatever and
sort of like cry or have a moment
i hope so um i mean it definitely like
if we
if we take a step back it certainly
seems like it's moving in that direction
um and i think part of it is also
recognizing
you know the old classic masculinity
is so ridiculous you know when we see
like tough guys taking themselves
seriously
it's like yeah you don't seem tough you
just seem it seems silly
you know and it just it
it just doesn't make sense anymore you
know maybe it made sense
thousands of years ago when you're like
fighting bears
to protect your family and be able to
like
sleep in your cave but now like
like an example of like tough guys being
ridiculous is like
two macho guys getting in a fight over a
parking space
you know people are willing to punch
each other in the face
for a parking space or like some guy
who's like super angry
because his sports team didn't win it's
like the sports team's not even in the
town where you live
there's no people on the sports team
you've ever met
that they're all making millions of
dollars worthy whether they win or lose
why is this guy upset yeah you know and
i'm not
criticizing sports sports are great i'm
just saying like
these expressions of traditional macho
masculinity are just
to just kind of ridiculous yeah
yeah well you know one of the things
that i love
giving my mentally giving myself this
perspective of
you know because i can fall into the
trap of trying to be perfect or trying
to
do certain things and fitting inside of
my own mental box
and but usually in a line alignment with
sort of perfectionism
or uh something in the in that realm
and when i do that i don't give anyone
else permission
to not be perfect right so it's in the
vulnerability which you do in so many
aspects you give permission to people
to make unique music you give permission
to people
to be honest about their childhood you
give
you know in in our flaws we actually
were so much more relatable because like
you said
15 minutes ago everybody's going through
crap
and so it's in our vulnerability that
we're now relatable but we also then
give the other person permission
to show us them
yeah yeah without question and the
perfectionism you're talking about
um most of my friends are women
and i see so many women it's
heartbreaking like how crippled they are
by the pursuit of perfectionism
right you know and this this idea that
they can only present themselves
as the most perfectly put together
version of who they are you know if
they're going to
write a song it has to be perfect if
they're going to
you know do anything in public it has to
be perfect
and i'm like yeah you be good
you know like it's it's good to you know
like if you're gonna
make a song make a good song but like
the the humanity of expression and
connection is so much more interesting
than
perfection you know i mean i'm sure
we've we've all had that experience
where like
maybe you go on a date and like you're
with someone who has like made this huge
effort to be perfect
and there's nothing to relate to you
know like and you almost
you almost want to pull them aside and
say like just like who are you
really like like like what makes you cry
what are your insecurities what do you
look like with no makeup what do you
know like just like
i almost feel like that would be the
perfect first date is like two people
come together
at their work not their worst their
meanest but like looking their worst
you know maybe don't even bathe for a
couple of days beforehand
and like see the connection you have
there as opposed to like
two perfectly put together people
going to an elegant place and having an
elegant night like there's
that's fun but there's no honesty there
totally
yeah there's no the like so going back
to like my mindset of this sort of like
intention or frequency or energy like
there's no tr there's no it's not real
it's in the head and not in the body
and that's something for me that i have
worked on myself is pulling information
from the head down into the body and
embodying it
and so i'm curious because you said like
a song and perfection
and then i think are there times where
you've recorded
and you know yes there's like a perfect
way to and again i don't record music
but you know there's like
executing something with perfection and
then there's executing something with
perfect vulnerability which is
maybe the voice crackles a little or
maybe something but there's like
something about it
it's kind of like a picture maybe where
you see somebody and they're like
smiling and then you see them like turn
and like catch a moment
like the cop moment has so much more
energy than the posed moment even though
they're both smiling pictures
so similarly with a song it's like you
can you can sing it beautifully
or you can sing it with like a little
bit of like that the the the caught
moment of like the emotion of it and
have you chosen
or has that happened to you where you
record something and you're like i don't
know there's just something about that
one i know it's not perfect but let's
that's the that's that's the one we're
putting in the song
well exactly what you're describing
happened because i work with quite a lot
of singers
and what you're describing used to
happen a lot where like
you know i would be working with a
singer they would do a rough run-through
of a song and be great
and then we'd do the official
run-through
and it wouldn't be nearly as interesting
and so
lately well for the last like maybe even
10 years what i do is when i work with a
singer i basically
record all of their rough takes and i
tell them i'm like okay we just i just
need to get like microphone levels let's
just run through it a couple times and
like
when we're done and i'll say to them
like okay like i just want to run
through it a few times so you can get
familiar with it and then i'll say to
them and then we'll do
you know the official version
keeping in mind i'm only recording them
doing the unofficial versions because i
know those are going to be the good ones
and
i've actually had singers get mad at me
because when i'm done recording the
unofficial versions i'll say to them
like okay
we're done and they'll they'll be taken
aback they'll be like but
but what about the perfect version i'm
like no this is great
we're fine and i've had some people
actually get
very mad at me because i have denied
them the ability to do something
technically perfect whereas what i want
is
emotionally honest